- Inge!
Inge, bitte!
Ich weiß, du bist wütend.
Und … und du hast jedes Recht dazu.
Ich habe gelogen.
Ich bin nicht Jacques,
ich habe keine Restaurants und …
und ich komme auch nicht aus Frankreich.
- Ging's immer ums Geld?
Das Geld zum Kaufen des Champagners,
das Geld zum Bezahlen des Urlaubs …
- Du bekommst alles wieder!
- Na, ich will nichts zurück, Jacques!
Kannst du das nicht verstehen?
Mir ist das Geld egal!
Ich brauche das zum Glücklichsein nicht.
War irgendetwas wahr?
- Was meinst du?
- Ich meine: War irgendetwas wahr
von dem, was du gesagt hast?
Und bitte …
bitte, dieses eine Mal, lüg' mich nicht an.
- Alles über mich ist gelogen.
Aber … aber jetzt seit unserem Urlaub ist
plötzlich alles wahr geworden.
Ich will einen Neuanfang mit dir.
Und ich glaube, dass alles
funktionieren kann.
Ich weiß, du musst ein furchtbares
Gefühlschaos haben
und ich weiß, dass ich schuld bin.
Aber mein Herz und mein Verstand
sagen mir …
Fang bloß nicht an, von Herz
und Verstand zu sprechen!
Beides hast du nicht.
Und ich glaube dir
kein einziges Wort mehr.
Ich will dich nie mehr wiedersehen,
Jacques!